hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to heavy bullets an indie
game that is supposed to be a roguelike
FPS it features perma death
lots of interesting traps and almost
guaranteed death I also saw that the
game grumps played this so I can't
possibly overlook it now
what's the Pala for this time customers
are dropping like flies because of a
security system this is a PR nightmare
someone has to manually reset the
security mainframe on level 8 put a
reward $5,000 for this services a lot of
lives will be lost
yeah they will good thing we're the only
ones paying them okay so our illustrious
employers do believe in us and believe
that we're going to be just fine at the
end of this actually Ava I watch like
everything the games upstairs
so I've whoa God that is quick okay it's
a lot quicker than I thought so I do
have an inkling Colette this game is all
about so I'm not gonna be caught to by
surprise when things are popping out all
the bushes right okay you're mine oh
yeah another one so poor point in the
game is that your bullets are really
heavy and then after you shoot something
you can pick it up again and also you
get money so that you can buy items and
upgrades and also store it for later
when you would never believed I
Wow okay excuse you so see you pick up
your bullets and then you reload them
all over again that way you can keep
your bullets that you had get these
special stuff and I know that that does
slow-mo style alright I don't know how
far I'm gonna get but I'm gonna try my
best to not suck which is usually oh
that's usually the strategy I employ and
most of my life I'm already not doing
the best at least I'm doing better than
some that's all that matters I thought I
saw something in that bushes turn now is
this a flower oh boy
anybody in the bushes anybody stop
spazzing out your money you're not
supposed to move
oh come on with this thing in the fall
are you there we go one down dodge I'm
like the best or something at least my
bullets hopped in the midair said in the
midair so that I can see where they are
all right so we're all done here right
the sensitivity all right [ __ ] okay
okay all right cause that's what I
thought
I recall this taking so long so what the
hell is the exit hello goodbye someone
else wanna pop out of me excuse me
okay wait a minute wait a minute
everybody's calm down why isn't there
been like enough shops for me gave the
grumps a bunch shot so I don't get
nothing I'll say I just haven't seen him
cuz I'm a dingus that seems like a
pretty good alternative by the way did
everyone like my scene here okay so I
was level one thankfully there's like 15
other levels so we're gonna get to that
soon enough we're gonna get to it real
soon really real soon yeah that looks
good I wasn't so hard oh absolutely not
I just gotta watch out for snakes like
you stay back you know it's good for you
after you're all right I saw ya
it's okay I didn't think it was actually
there
so I'm wondering dad some items said I
didn't see why I shouldn't see what they
did like life insurance I don't know
what life insurance did I'm not sure oh
god I saw body parts twitch I think go
like this that music going to think you
can mess with me I forgot that I had a
focus pill which made me things move in
slow motion which I apparently I can't
remember or talk what a bunch of bull
ass all my money went away I didn't use
it I didn't Bank it such a dingus okay
sighs again I'm all you this is only
gonna be one off but I want to get as
far as possible so I can say that I'm
good at games
and in gonna happen all right
so we need to Spade their level one cuz
obviously I'm far too skilled to be
stopped by this whoa what's this speed
pill Oh perfect exactly what I need when
I'm trying to speed through something I
forgot that shift was prom night
bottle beep boop boop so what is the
item not that well not that either
how do I use the item about what you see
item how do I use a freaking item
no one saw that okay no one saw that
okay this time it's for real I'm really
gonna get it down I'm gonna get it good
because I'm gonna be calm and collected
as I make my way through this maze it
was this way a red potion maybe I should
look up what the extras control for use
item is space coulda sworn I hit space
oh well woah that's right woah yeah
that's right anybody else
health is fault okay antidote well I'm
not poisoned so that's not entirely good
good for me okay anybody else wanna
tango a look at a red potion just in
time for me to need I don't most cure
this no I'm gonna Bank all my stuff I'm
gonna deposit all of it
I'm never gonna hold down on any of it
because if I die again I ain't gonna
miss no every shot instead of hitting
you the mouse is very sensitive you guys
don't even understand what the deal I'm
dealing with is I'm not complaining I'm
saying it's much harder than it looks
actually it's just as easy okay yay
anybody else give you all your money
give me all your money maybe I'm the
crazy killer murderer Robert give me all
your money blacks blam sorry
anybody else
hey guys would be slightly terrifying if
this was any kind of real life I knew it
no my reactions must be quicker no there
we go there we go there we go okay we're
fine suddenly give back one health
that's stupid that's stupid and I hate
it all right let's move on to level two
yeah I'm gonna do good I know all of
your doubt they're not cheering for me
but I'm gonna do good let's do good or
something no no no anybody else anybody
yeah no harm in checking you know no
harm in checking I gotta be more
accurate but this mouse is really way
too sensitive
everything is wages whoa you're coming I
need honey bullets actually I do need
bullets you know what but I do get a
movie baby baby okay so we're doing good
I'm just a bullet somewhere I can't find
it
where did bullet go oh it's awfully nice
that they do whoa yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah anymore turrets ah
starting to get apprehensive about
what's going on in this situation mm-hmm
I'm a man on the edge with a gun Oh
Oh you weren't even looking at me before
where are you going in all right got
more bullets so that means I can use
some some of my patented spam and spray
technique dead I think the dark ones are
poisonous
oh you're fast okay there's a lot of you
really fast anymore that's what I
thought from a mile away I can oh it's a
breakfast yes please thank you okay we
got here he'll answer don't focus pill
bullet magnet I don't need that I need
any of this what a bunch of baloney okay
I don't know where to get the key card
also that's that's something else that's
lost to me all in mine I don't need any
of this I need a bank for what I
inevitably die oh good boy
hello boy anybody else anybody else
skulking in the woods whoa whoa okay
that was a bit of a waste Oh what are
you alright then I got a key card I
think I got something it looks like a
key maybe that was a key card let me go
back if it'll let me go back remember
when I was watching the game bro played
us they couldn't go back I can't go back
Wow okay I can't go back without a
punishment I guess whoa
that's mildly creepy oh why what was the
point
wait could I just I could have just I
could have just I can't just go through
there hey what a piece of poop sorry
excuse my foul language no no
okay remember what I said I didn't need
that he'll probably need that he'll now
oh well whatever this is rogue like I
don't think there's any way to save my
death unless there's some weird thing
with the insurance but I'm sure on this
level everything's got to be sunshine
and rainbows there's gonna be no evil
monstrosity trying to kill me lose none
that are worse than what I've already
seen probably oh okay anybody else yeah
takes two to tango it takes one of me to
kill yo it's like five owner are you to
kill me huh who's the better man okay
laser did not see that totally lucked
out gotcha with skill and women vicar
we are jumping alive coins and whatnot I
need health
why isn't there been a freak fracking
vending machine it's like they want me
to die well so what kind of em I'm
always served down here still don't know
if the throw glove does grenades
disturbing who's like some large bulbous
thing that's right no I have the option
to nope I feel a heal
I need that badly just checking yes give
it to me a your delicious heals okay
max life up I would have been useful too
bad I have no time for that whoa god
damn it I'm Way too [ __ ] about that
bye
oh god you bullet bastard I thought you
were something crawling towards me a
weirdo banking deposit a lot all mini
Anees deposit all my money sent back to
my family and gwenna suave whoa don't
ask about Greta suave look the situation
there is very big very precarious don't
dodge back the way it's coming yes and
when it shoots you I know I probably
shouldn't shoot things so far away
either because that's gonna keep bullets
away from me whereas I need bullets in
my face preferably not the bullets of
these guys I'm getting good at this game
or something it's almost as if I'm
skilled I can't possibly be true okay
whoa rockin yeah throw cuff didn't do it
jack whoa don't feel bad
wait come on go get you looks like a
magic
okay I'm out of bombs there we go okay a
guy down it's gotta be worms in here I
just got to be careful Oh God
tall grass it's flying there is it worth
it just had a check you know be sure it
was nothing there
good I'm glad nothing there anyway
anybody okay got quiet don't be quiet on
me freaking me out
that's what it's stressful because of
the risk I can I know what's at stake
the embarrassment of the entire Internet
is mo Germany Jam jams whoa we're making
it I can't believe we're making it I
can't believe I'm coming this far I'm
good at games
oh hey let's carry on whoa okay good
thing it only takes one shot for all
these creatures otherwise I'd be in the
way your friend exploded into a whole
bunch of bits I was cool when that
happened I need a bank now cuz I might
need to buy something who knows
face no no actually you're beautiful I
just jealous that's why I'm sure yeah
I'm spotting these guys dead end huh
that's good for me
mmm come on come on be a little more
skilled hello right in front it whoa
okay this ain't good sit why yo
Oh God Oh you have a you have a
vulnerable but yeah okay I don't have
any bombs but there he's down okay
we're good we're good we're good good
boy you gonna sneak up on me what's that
a pokemons sound no idea there we go
that's much better
all right backpack I'm guessing that
allows me to hold one more item running
shoes sound good I'll buy both
press tab to use okay yay what is that
make me go just a little bit faster I
didn't need to go faster faster is what
kills me low blow what did I get
did I get the key card is that the sound
of me getting the key card whatever that
is it sold out
can't buy that I shouldn't have banked
all my money it's gonna be the last time
I play this so if I die I'm dead
okay got you got you go whoa whoa whoa
bom-bom-bom on dude oh you can't do that
that's cheating you went through a wall
damn it
there we go damn it I was doing so good
that's right that's really careful I'm
on the last leg oh god oh god oh god
they're gonna get me Oh No
there's somebody that Oh girls I ain't
gonna risk it not this time
not what I have so much at stake how
intense this is never mind never mind
never mind I'm sorry for everything I've
ever done I'm just worried about things
going through the walls again
cuz that was fair I've got all this
money but there was an L I know all the
alarm bells are very helpful okay that
all is that all that was all okay I
don't want to bank it what have you got
discount life insurance I would all be
pretty good I'm gonna sneak up on you
gotcha G Christmas no no no no no not
through the wall again
where are you where are you where are
you God I don't want to get closer okay
where is he I'm out of bombs he's right
there he's gonna blame all over my face
stop fear until you wait today oh god oh
god oh god what a douchebag
what a fluffernutter want to flip lead
ooh what a piece of poop all right okay
that's all she wrote so thank you all so
much for watching if you want this game
unfortunately it's not free it is $10
unseen so if you think this is worth it
it's randomly generated roguelike and
obviously it's a bit of a challenge so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos check out
the description for more awesome games
that I played in the past there's a lot
of them thanks again everybody and as
always I will see
in the next video one way and that is
[Music]